il a parole l'état madame bérengère
poletti merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
certes l'actualité est dense mais
n'oublions pas la détresse de nos
agriculteurs
vous êtes aux manettes depuis quatre ans
et il meurt en silence
c'est vrai le secteur agricole dépend
beaucoup des politiques européennes
mais ce que décide la france n'est pas
neutre ce que vous avez décidé depuis
quatre ans n'est pas neutre les charges
pèsent lourdement sur nos agriculteurs
comme sur nos artisans et nos petites
entreprises et les contraintes qu'on
leur impose sont plus lourdes en france
qu'ailleurs
par exemple sur les normes les bâtiments
d'élevage sur la directive nitrates sur
l'instruction des dossiers pac
tout est toujours plus compliquée pour
les agriculteurs français ça n'est pas
par les coups médiatiques ou les
annonces de plans de soutien sans
efficacité juillet 2015 septembre 2015
janvier 2016 février 2016 que vous leur
apporterez des solutions passer aux
actes dans nos territoires rien n'a
changé près de la moitié des éleveurs
sont dans le rouge
beaucoup baissent les bras et veulent
arrêter leur activité
un agriculteur se suicident tous les
deux jours
ils vendent leur lait à perte les prix
des céréales et de la viande se sont
effondrés ils sont accablés par les
emprunts et perdent de l'argent chaque
jour travailler alors que la
pluviométrie du mois de juin a entraîné
des dégâts importants plus de dix mille
hectares yens dans les ardennes que de
tergiversations de votre ministère pour
les aides pac sur ces surfaces
vous indiquez dans un premier temps
qu'il faut s'engager dans une procédure
calamité puis en fait non il faut
impérativement déclaré toutes les
communes impactées en catastrophe
naturelle puis en fait non
un arrêté préfectoral suffira voilà
comment sont gérées les difficultés des
agriculteurs
qu allez vous enfin faire monsieur le
ministre pour épargner aux agriculteurs
les tourments d'une réglementation
instable et tatillonne et qu'ils
puissent enfin vivre de leur travail
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll mines des agriculteurs
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt madame
la députée vous évoquez beaucoup de
sujets vous avez quoi particulier les
sujets liés
aux installations classées je voudrais
vous rappeler que la législation que
vous dénoncez a été assouplie sous ce
gouvernement est que si elles étaient
difficiles et difficilement applicable
c'était von en vos décisions
madame la députée donc sur tous ses
établissements en particulier son
établissement d'élevage c'est nous qui
avons simplifié l'ensemble des règles
ils cpe aujourd'hui applicables sur la
question de la directive nitrates elle a
été signé il ya quelques années une
quinzaine vingtaine d'années aujourd'hui
elle s'applique là aussi avec des règles
que vous avez vous-même mise en oeuvre
et que nous sommes chargés aujourd'hui
malheureusement d'appliquer avec le
souci de la protection de
l'environnement et de la protection des
agriculteurs
vous avez évoqué ensuite la question des
calamités et des inondations je suis
désolé de vous le dire il ya jamais eu
de changement ce que vous évoquez sur
les communes liées à l'état de
catastrophe naturelle
c'est pour les aides pac donc toutes ces
communes et tous les agriculteurs qui
ont des surfaces pointe est inondée dans
ces communes en état de catastrophe
naturelle seront versés et pour celles
qui ne sont pas les surfaces dans des
communes en état de catastrophe
naturelle ce sont des arrêtés
préfectoraux qui viendront justifier le
fait qu'on verse des aides aux
agriculteurs enfin vous avez évoqué et
je vais y revenir
la question des aides pac là aussi
apurement de l'europe pour des
versements des aides de 2008 jusqu'à
2012 qui n'étaient pas conformes aux
surfaces déclarées
il a fallu refaire l'ensemble du
registre parcellaire graphique pendant
l'année 2015 ce qui nous a fait perdre
du retard mais comme moi je suis si les
agriculteurs madame la députée nous
avons versé des avances que ça soit en
2015 à la fois en octobre et en décembre
ça sera la même chose en 2016 dès
octobre 90 % c'était une question aussi
qu'avait posé monsieur le député d
octobre 90% en avance parce que c'est
les agriculteurs qui compte la parole